???: Here. To me.
Mark: Hi...
Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Subnautica now
I know I said that I wasn't going to be back into the game until there was a major update
or the full release of the game and
Thankfully that wait is over. They just released the voice of the deep update and this is why
I waited to go in there
I waited to see what was going to happen if we were going to use the hatching enzymes on those eggs. Oh hey all right then
Sorry oh, hi, okay. I'm getting it now. Okay. Let me in let me in
Oooookay
(all system's online) ..Anyway
The reason I waited is because this update is major this entire research facility is now fully operational
And we have everything that we need to be able to get what we need to get.
Uh, I don't know
Oh my God !
???: I am what... you seek.
Want to... help you.
Okay (confused Markimoo)
Alrighty then if that's what yoooou say...
Ah. Okay, so hi. Hello. God dammit get off my boat you frickin frickers!
but either way
The update is here, and this precursor base is fully operational alongside every single one of those ding-dang
portals, at least me think so me, not sure so let me go look at it.
So I just came in here to get some more food so that I can make it through, all the research that I'm gonna need
to do to be able to get through all of this...And once I get a marble melooon I guess that's enough for meeeee.
More than I would have wanted. I hope I don't puke, okay there. We go one more (Eek) okay!
We're good to go, so if we go down in here.
We're gonna see everything that is available to us. Why is it alone? Oh, why are you so creepy?
Why you so ROAR!!? (ง ͠° ͟ل͜ ͡°)งWhy dont you go...?!
Woa well, I gotta get those guys off there, but I gotta get in here before the lagg takes me.
Okay
We're in and so right now you guys will see there's an actual honest-to-goodness terminal here.
I don't have to hack my way in anymore. Oh...
I've had this blue key forever!
And finally get to open!!
Good-bye blue key apparently. I'm gonna take Mr.Fister  in here, and we're gonna see our own way down\ (•◡•) /
We're gonna see everything that we need to see, how you skittering bastards. OooooOOooooOh
Boingy.Now it should look much the same as it did before there shouldn't be a whole lot new here.
So I'm only going to go over the things that are definitely new like this research terminal right here.
So I think I've read that before that's talking about the emperor and them containing It, here. So whuu.
So that means this, is the complete egg
research area. All of the emperor's oooooh...
UUuuuuuuuUUuuuuuhuuuuuuuuuuuuuuH
UUoooooH!
UUUUUHHNOOO!!! (ಥ﹏ಥ)
Why would they kill a baby? I mean to research the disease and try to save lives I guess.. oh
Superficial damage to the specimen indicates who was forcibly removed from its egg casing terminated for dissection..UH
digestive system enzyme production..
indicates potential for full vaccination against effects alien bacterium how our fetus had not fully completed..
gestation internal organ development is insufficient for enzyme production. Aaah.
Okay, so they needed a healthy baby, but they decided to cut one out of an egg, for no goddamn reason!
I may have read that before but I am equally...
Outraged now. The updates mentioned something about the piping project now. I glanced over this in this unfinished area over here
oh over here and
I mentioned that there was these pipes here.
These fascinating..
Otherworldly pipes. Pumping water to and from the attached pipe network analysis the water composition flowing in it indicates
It is being drawn from the different biomes. Now, we read that before,
but the revelation that I didn't realize before is that the
reason this all exists is number one to be able to contain the biomes with which to research the
specimens that they contain here in this facility
but also as an added ancillary benefit the peepers that live in the tank with the
emperor Leviathan
traverse to and from
this area and
back to the surface there goes one and
with it contained some of Enzyme 42 and Enzyme 42 is
the thing that makes sure that the life on this planet is still alive
There's a reason while life is still here while the Carar bacterium was still raging
everywhere, and why it still infected me and yet, everything else is still alive
And maybe even why the people of this place..
like the
humans that landed here before why they were able to survive so long if they were eating
If they were eating the creatures here then that would explain why..
they were able to survive for so long. I don't have another blue one!
Is there another blue one in here?
You guys seen a blue.. or and I'll be back with you.
I hope I don't have to make one because I did not come up with the..
didn't come up with the plans for the correct one. So I've discovered the location of the blue artifact it is..
Obviously still in the primary power plant which is above us, in the lava castle as it's colloquially known
But, I was supposed to be able to get a crafting recipe once I pick that up.
Buuuuuuut
Have to go get it because I believe all
the spawns should have reset so that means there should be another one up there, and I ain't gonna cheat and get one
I aint gonna do that so I'll be right back in a minor..
adventure to be able to get back before I have to go on and go forward. I'll see you soon. Oh also,
I should mention that there have been update to this now. The engine is offline and you have to turn it back on. ARE YOU JUST..
GONNA JOIN US FOR THE RIDE? Fine..
That seems ominously necessary!
AH! That's right. You can rig for silent running now.
So you can be silent at any speed! OOOoohHHH!
THAT IS THE OPPOSITE OF SILENT! OH GOD!  Are we okay. Are we okay? We're not okay, are we? OOOh! That seems like the opposite of we're okay okay okay.
AAH
FIRE, FIRE??? Oh God the dubstep gonna start pounding! ヾ(⌐■_■)ノ♪ Oh this is  horrible? (Oh my God! x3)
Well they're all mad at me. Launch decoy! Scadooshki. OWE that didn't help, literally ah OH they're going for it! Oh my God
They're going for all this is an adventure that I didn't want under taaaake. Oh, there's gonna be a tight squeeze.   ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Oh, that's ooh hoo, hoo, hoo. Hee hee hee!
I can make it, I can make that. URRGH. I can make that. Oh, I hope I make that.. I hope I make that!
OOOOFOOFFOFOO
Shibity bibity! why didn't I take my.. Why didn't I take Mr.Fistir? Oh my God, peeper in my face.
I'm going down to my bare skinish, with my dick wagon out. CAAACHOOOW! ..And with that comes the kaboow.
Give give give give give to me
Thank you
I got a blueprint with that which I should have gotten a long time ago, but I didn't.
So off I go then back into the depths of Hell. There's a bit of
destruction in this world.
Oh, God! DON'T HIT MEEEEEEEEEEEEEEE!!
EEEEEHH IT'S AFTER MEEEEEEYEYEYE.
YEYEYE YA HE HO HA
HEY. We're gonna go, we're gonna go, we're gonna go, we're gonna go, we're gonna go, we're gonna goooo
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
We're gonna goooooooo.
Yeeeeeeeeeee.
Oh it seems.
That seems a bit extreme. ♪~ ᕕ(ᐛ)ᕗ I got a go take care of that before it burns my ass in the middle room.
(♪~ ᕕ(ᐛ)ᕗ Markimoo singing ♪~ ᕕ(ᐛ)ᕗ)
And you can't hear me. I don't know what you're talking about.
We got an emergency speed. We're gunning it out my asssss.
I am not going to bother you until I punch you in your dick, and when I do that..
You'll be like ooh, thank you markiplier. You're so nice. OOhkay.
That was a goddamn nightmare. That was a nightmare unlike any I've seen beeeeeeeeeefore.
But we're baaaaaaack
so
We have the blue artifact, so there is no more waiting here. There is no more skedaddle skadoodle.
I meant to just go straight through this, but it decided to be a little bit of a douche. Yeah, aaaaaaaaah.
AAAH
There you go.
OH
Weird it as simple as that. The supposed power supply is just meant to take down the power of a shield. Okay.
By the way, this is ooh
translating local alien broadcast. WARNING vaccine development program terminated.  Emperor egg hatching project terminated. Live specimen terminated. Evacuate immediately.
Weeeeeell, I think you're wrong about one thing here.
There's a gursh darn live specimen alive...
right in here.
Here we go
heeeeellooo.
(Sea Emperor grunts(?))
Hey!
Ohhhh ho!
Ah ha ha ha!
Hi, Mama (づ￣ ³￣)づ
Sea Emperor: Are you here.. to play?
The others came but played... alone. They bored me.
Now they're gone.
And instead... I have you.
Mark: Yeah, you do. Heeeey
ƪ(˘⌣˘)Ʃ
My name is Markiplier. How you doing? How long you been down here, I'm uuuh.
Here to play ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) hey wait. No come on. I said my name is Markiplier. They usually get some! Oh big momma.
I've been waiting for this day. Oh, don't worry. I'm here.
to play ʘ‿ʘ
Would you like to play a game? ʘ‿ʘ Hello?
Can I help you?
Excuse me. OOooooh!
My what big.. legs you have oh passive babbers. Oh?
All right, all right a we janky a little bit, but alright!
Okay, let me step out..
for a little bit.
Hmm rare plankton like life-form, oh-
Wait, I can breathe down here
Wait, no, I can't that was a lie. I'm just a freakin idiot. hi. I'm Momma!. How are you doing? \ (•◡•) /
Oh these your kids. Oh, they're lovely! <3
They take after their mother you know what I mean, hahaha. Yeah!
Oh, I need to, I need to fuel it ah that'd be smart. Hi-Yaaah! Take my fuuuuuuel. Oh that one worked!
S E: My young want to hatch. To play outside this place. We have been here so long.
The others had ways of giving passage to the outside. I asked them for this, but they could not hear.
(Sea Emperor roars)
If you can hear, you can help. If you can help.. I will tell what the others wanted to badly to know.
Mark: Thank you!
Thank you!
WWWWWOOOOOO \ (•◡•) /Thank you
What did they want to know..was it? How to cure-
OOOOHHHH!
Was it how to cure?
Tell me it was how to cure..
Ooooooo
OOOUUUUUUU
I'm tinglin  (•◡•)
All right, so now if I get hatching enzymes..
I'll be able to
get what i need to get and
Hatch these eggs.
But how do I get hatching enzymes you might ask? WELL..
I think the answer might lie in waiting right over here excuse me, sir. I've got destiny calling..
- okay, all right well
S E: You gave me what I asked for. I give you what you seek.
Mark: oh..
S E: My young cannot be forced from thier shells.They must be coaxed.
This is what the others cannot see.
I give you this secret willingly. I hope I will not be disappointed again.
Mark: Hoooooo...
You shouldn't have trusted me. I'm gonna make millions off of these. Ha ha ha ha.
Okay, how do I make this..
hatching enzymes here?
All right Gabe's feather seeds, sea crown seed Membrane tree seeds...I just- What?
What are those!?
What are those? What are those? I don't even know what those are!
What are those? are you bowing? That's so sweet and misguided. I don't deserve that. I'm an asshole
all right ooooh.
I don't know where we're going noooow. I hope it's somewhere clean I've pissed myself uh
ah ah ah
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAH
All right fine you want to play that game? Huh, okay?
Well, I guess that gets me to the surface quick.
But this is it this is what I've been waiting for where'd you go here there? It's just dark in here now.
Oh there, you are okay, but lights decided to come in here.
But that's what I've been waiting for that's what I've been waiting for. Oh.
I want to work for it. I don't even know these are
What are thooose?!
What Gabes feather? What's the sea crown?
What's a Membrane tree? I think I know what the membrane tree. Is that the big thing with the thing?
I don't know. What's a rouge cradle?
I've got a whole new adventure ahead of me and many more episodes of Subnautica
waiting so that I can hatch these damn eggs and see if I can cure
myself so big momma don't wait too long. You ain't gonna be disappointed about nothing. ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) Oh, you winked at me
I saw that so thank you everybody so much for watching. Thank you for being patient for the return of Subnautica
And as always I will see you in the next video!
bye-bye \ (•◡•) /
(Commence Sea Emperor Wink-age!)